hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer a question from one of our
YouTube readers viewers I guess Rihanna
who wrote insane I want to start a
business but I want to help small
businesses be more successful I want to
help by starting a consulting company
but who would want to listen to someone
who's never owned the business how do I
become more credible Thank You Rihanna
so thanks for the question Rihanna so
when I'm giving advice to entrepreneurs
to have them start up their own business
the number one thing I always recommend
is is build the business around your
passion so you've got into something
really excited about you you'll jump
through you know brick walls to solve
something that kind of keeps you going
and gets the energy pumping and the
blood flowing so if you found that with
helping small business owners so that
that's a great start so you found your
passion the next thing I usually
recommend doing for somebody just
starting up without a lot of experience
is work to learn so go find somebody
who's doing exactly what you're doing or
what you want to do and work for them
for six months or three months or a year
just to get a sense of how the industry
works to a make sure that it is
something that you want to do and be
also learn all the tricks of the trade
from somebody who is in your industry
it's a great way to learn about the
business figure out all the mistakes on
somebody else's watch and also get paid
to do it so you're getting paid to learn
about how to be a successful business
owner in your field so as much as to
also try to find somebody you might be
able to intern with or get a job with at
the start who does exactly what you want
to try to do to learn from their
experience beyond that you got to start
building up a base so if you have no
experience it might be hard to convince
people to come on board with you and
sign you up as a supplier but you might
have to do things for free at the
beginning or a super low cost so you're
building up your portfolio you're
building up your experience and you're
building up case study so you can say
hey I helped this person go from here to
here so at the beginning you're looking
for small clients people who could
become testimonials or case studies I
need
if you're not making money off of them
you're building up your portfolio so
that when other clients come to you you
can show them hey you've got all this
work done behind you and you know you're
credible expert the last thing I would
try to do here in terms of just getting
started is try to build up your
expertise by creating content so if you
have a blog write great content on your
website that talks about how small
business owners can help grow their
companies you can create YouTube videos
just like I'm doing here you can share
your thoughts in the video or you can
just answer questions if you see
questions coming in you may not have an
audience yet of people who are asking
you questions but you can go to a forum
of entrepreneurs and see what people are
talking about and just create a video
response and get back to somebody
through your YouTube video depends on
how you know if you like being in front
of the camera or if you prefer the right
but start creating expert content and if
it's publishing on your own blog or if
you're doing guest posting for other
blogs you're starting to build a little
bit of an authority presence again you
have to have enough of a base knowledge
to be able to create this great content
if you don't really know what you're
talking about yet then you have to go
back and get the experience by working
for somebody else and by starting on
this little project with clients but
once you feel you have a bit of a base
knowledge then you can start creating
content and people find it and think wow
this is really great stuff they might
contact you or at least sign up for your
newsletter or take whatever next step
you want them to take so hopefully that
helps it is a bit of a process it's
probably gonna take a lot longer than
you think it's gonna take and be you
know require a lot of energy but
hopefully it's something that you're
really passionate about you believe in
and this is something want to do for the
next 20 years
then it'll be worth the investment and
be super rewarding for you as you
continue to grow so thank you for the
question if those of you watching if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below makes you want to do more of
these videos for you and if you have a
comment about this video or you have a
question for your own business
feel free leave it in the comment
section below I always read those and
try to respond to everybody who does
right in so thank you and I'll see you
on the next episode
you